muy buenas tardes nos conocemos con mi
que hace bastante tiempo las
circunstancias en las que nos conocimos
de alguna manera me presentaron me he
tal cual era yo llegué a su estudio de
grabación en miraflores y él está
acompañado de dos personajes extraños
un británico creo que la que hablaba de
partidos volador existe ningún programa
para viajar por el cosmos etcétera y una
negra descomunalmente bella una negra
absolutamente espectacular yo iba a
conocerla a mickey pero en mi que en su
modestia me dijo no me vas a conocer a
mí vamos a ir a matute a la universidad
de matute a conocer a una banda de
música llamada del pueblo del barrio
cuando regresamos de esta epifanía para
mi nueva completamente de conocer a el
pueblo del barrio regresamos al estudio
de mickey y entonces a bien o estaba
grabado o fue una aparición o era uno de
los marcianos del gringo que nos
acompañaba empezó a tocar una especie de
plan plan en un cajón peruano y esta
negra escultural se levantó y comenzó a
avanzar quién era esta mujer esta mujer
era la princesa de una tribu africana en
concreto de lesotho de soto es un
pequeño país en medio de sudáfrica uno
de los países que sufre que inventó para
de alguna manera desembarazarse en la
época de la parte de negocios incómodos
y ella dijo que esa era la música de sus
tribus africanas
y así conocí a miki gonzález a que trigo
personas en mi gonzález ni él lo sabe ni
el rosal
- lo voy a saber yo yo tengo que tomar
agua con frecuencia durante esta
entrevista por algo que comparto con mi
que se llama cáncer yo acabo de sufrir
nueva sesión de radioterapia me han
quitado la saliva de la boca y entonces
tengo que tomar agua
constantemente méxico multas
hazte amigo de jennifer cómo te sientes
yo estoy bien por suerte no vosotros si
tengo saliva tengo algunos problemas
pero
estamos compartiendo este momento que no
sabemos cuánto tiempo vamos a durar si
es así que mírenlos bien y presten
atención
[Música]
miki gonzález es el gran trovador del
siglo 20 y parte del 21 en el perú
buenas mi opinión miki gonzález nos
enseña a que la música debe servir para
algo más allá de ella misma
miki gonzález es un músico que ha
acompañado el devenir social del perú
durante todo este tiempo con canciones
que van a ser inolvidables que van a
retratar los momentos difíciles que
hemos vivido y los momentos pocos
gloriosos que hemos vivido también el
otro día se conmemoraba un puerto del
siglo de akundún acude es el gran ning
de integración nacional es el gran
homenaje a la cultura negra el perú su
canción sobre tocache es una canción que
con el solo nombre con la sola mención
nos retrotrae y nos empuja a conocer una
etapa difícil de nuestra historia y no
digo nada las sorpresas que nos da el
cada vez más juvenil mickey con esta
música electrónica salía de no sé qué
planeta de los ejes satélite pregunta
cmic y tú te has propuesto hacer estas
crónicas a la manera de un cronista
colonial o incaico o esto es algo que ha
ido saliendo y no sabe bien por qué hay
un poco de eso porque si me gusta contar
historias ahora
escuchando todas las ponencias de esta
noche
si hay una hay común y no un hilo
conductor
que pude sacar que era mientras más
información tengas más empoderado estás
me gusta eso que dice frank
[Música]
entonces sí y es la formación que estuve
escuchando escuchando los luz escuchando
bob dylan en mi adolescencia entonces si
contar una historia no yo siempre pensé
que si venían de otro planeta o se
destruía la civilización y en 2000 o
5000 años se encontraban y ponían
tocache y digamos se podía saber un poco
cómo era nuestra vida no como los huacos
un poco si calculaban que habían pasado
y
así en la historia si definitivamente es
así es es contar historias de lo que se
vive muy sencillas todo lo que está ahí
y esta implicación como llegada mediante
una llamada telefónica como en el caso
de tocache no o de otra forma no no no
la inspiración no se sabe nunca dónde
llega yo por eso cuando decidí ser
músico paraba con una grabadora y
entonces la sacada y así ahora el
teléfono tarareó lo guardo las ideas y
todo eso porque luego no vuelven esa es
la cosa y quería decir una cosa también
que es importante que me identifico con
con percy con lo de la burbuja de
después de escuchar toda esta cosa de de
las redes y todo esto
en otro planeta
si es importante qué
y todo lo que yo todo en todas las cosas
las que yo me he fijado
eran cosas que normalmente nadie le daba
importancia
y también esta es la parte del alma y
creo que hay que tener una parte
dramática
podemos darle un tono un poco hasta el
trágico
nosotros ponemos hoy es él
o sea siempre las cosas creo que al
origen yo me fijaba son las cosas
digamos qué
que no eran lo que se fijaban los demás
yo creo que tuve esa persistencia y no
sé por qué tenía la convicción porque no
no por nada no porque no porque quería
no porque tenía un sueño ni nada no no
para nada porque no sabía hasta ahora no
sé qué es lo que quiero hacer con mi
vida
pero si la compulsión tan fuerte de
de hacer algo como por ejemplo conocí a
amador ballumbrosio que me dio césar
calvo desde ese día
la
o sea la fuerza que tenía de este
personaje
yo yo yo lo tenía claro o sea esto era
algo único y yo tengo por ejemplo fotos
que estamos bambas miranda y yo
la primera vez que fuimos al carmen
césar y yo fuimos en un carro a conocer
amador después
decidimos hacer un almuerzo entonces la
siguiente semana entonces dejamos una
plata para comprar la comida y llegamos
el grupo de amigos era césar
qué es eso tenía no sé si diez años más
que yo más o menos
y está [ __ ] benavides que hizo fotos
que se las he pedido y creo que las
pérdidas no las encuentra eran un par de
amigas de de césar gente de digamos de
su edad su generación
y después estaba andrés soto que era el
grupo con el que yo tocaba yo tocaba
guitarra con andrés estaba en miranda
que tocaba el cajón y carlos espinoza
que tocaba el saxo y habíamos llevado al
tío tato guzmán y es el papá de rosita
guzmán que era nuestro mentor yo trato
en un día lo encontramos
a las 11 de la mañana por la avenida a
pardo un lunes digo que haces por acá
porque él vive en mar y hasta por
raymond y en el barranco que haces por
acá no sobre un sube te vamos a llevar
sobrino yo he estado acá con unas chicas
tomando whisky y echado en unos cojines
tienen 60 pero parecen de 40 no
estaríamos veintitantos quizás hablando
ahora lo comprendo entonces bueno ya me
estoy desviando entonces fue lo que
estamos esas cosas que le pasan a uno
entonces hicimos este este almuerzo ahí
en el carmen visa de patear al armador
por primera vez
su sala era un poco como este espacio un
poquito menos y el zapateado está bajo
selur y está a mi lado tocando el violín
y él y él era caporal y estaba él
zapateando ahí delante el piso era de
tierra y había una ventanita por una
entrada el sol y el polvo de la tierra
eran como si cuatro zapateadores y el
hielo en el centro o seis posiblemente
entonces había como una como como cuando
pone un hielo seco y ahora es humo para
que las luces reflejen entonces se
reflejaba esta ventana a la luz la danza
del pan alivio y amador haciendo estos
movimientos de la lámpara
con esta con esta cosa mágica de cómo se
movía él
y yo me transporte a otra realidad como
el libro de las puertas de la percepción
y donde él explica cuando toma peyote
que accede a otra realidad en castellano
hay una edición que sale con las puertas
de la percepción se llama cielo infierno
que son técnicas de la humanidad donde
se permite está
[Música]
pase a otras realidades por ejemplo las
recuerdo y un poco de ley en los 70 pero
las catedrales góticas
están las catedrales y estas iglesias
están cerradas
hay muchas velas porque no hay luz
eléctrica la gente cantando los
ventanales la luz
entre el bajo oxígeno y tal produce
una exaltación mística el freak o muy
bien también una cosa que las
flagelaciones no era para mortificar pse
sino que eso producía también un heridas
que había un como infecciones y había un
cambio de proteínas y esto también
producía una exaltación mística
interesantísimo y eso me pasó viendo a
madroa y ambrosio cuando te escucho
hablar estoy escuchando hablar a un gurú
estoy escuchando hablar a un chamán
estoy luchando hablar a un monje budista
los habitantes oa los tres juntos en
coro no no no no no no no
una vez me preguntaron en una comida
también estaba explicando mi punto de
vista de una cosa y una gente que no me
conoce
eres antropólogo y no es lo que veo
un poco para terminar la idea por
ejemplo yo estaba ahí con amador y bam
bam te tenemos fotos de a quien conocí
por ti de chino domínguez chino mi mejor
periodista gráfico es por si acaso
porque américa la hija del zambo cavero
mickey hablando el chino domínguez
con ambos hemos tratado nosotros pero
bien
y ahí esta foto que estamos bang bang y
yo tocando en el corral de amador
y me veo yo hoy con 26 años
bam bam y yo somos los únicos blancos
estamos tratando de hacer un grupo de
cultura afroperuana porque lo que había
en el carmen yo sólo conocía de los
hijos de nicómedes fabulosos y de perú
negro eso era mi referente de lo que es
la cultura negra díaz y la igualdad de
los años afroperuana como dirían ahora
de los años 70
entonces y tú ves
me he encontrado acá por ejemplo que fue
muy emotivo hermoso que estaba sirviendo
que
trabajaba en la casa de mis padres en la
recepción es mi padre tenía trabajaba en
una corporación española trabajaba en
tabakalera y en fosforeras y esa casa
era como una embajada porque allí iban
todos como él representaba a un grupo
económico importante he conocido
personalidades ahí conocido y no ya no
voy a decir porque estaba linda la
comercial iba a decir éste no lo vas a
delatar político si no pero bueno el
asunto es que me encontré con con este
mosso
y fue una cosa muy emotiva de ver lo que
él esté vivo y entre las mismas y de
vídeo tiene 90 años por mandarle saludos
tal así que él
que se podía pensar sin mí
se puede hablar en inglés no la chica
que es tan sociable en inglés es un
background como se dice no se dice en
español background la grand-am iba draw
le valoraron social digamos yo fui yo he
ido al colegio privado no tengo carrera
universitaria porque ya ese es otro tema
que es para el próximo año del otro t
pero digamos si tú ves esa foto que
estoy escribiendo estoy yo con bam bam y
un montón de negros y bailando y el hijo
le salió un malo a gonzález y sí sí se
suponía que yo tenía que haber terminado
una carrera y ser un ejecutivo y
trabajar
yo empecé estudiando ingeniería
industrial que era un poco lo que las
chicas de que el colegio te empuja una
cosa y y
y al final por suerte fui soy un
transgresor nato
no me gusta hacer caso
o no puedo hacer caso puedes es superior
y por eso decía la compulsión de fijarme
en ciertas cosas que solo para mí tienen
interés
o sea quién iba a decir que algo qué
nadie iba al carmen era un cajón
entiendes no había cajón había entrado
en desuso nadie le importaba tener un
cajón porque no lo soy no nos iba a
sacar de mi socia de repente entiendes o
sea los loosers
[Música]
para mí no es no había luz se les eran
eran los máximos y yo desde el día 1 que
conocía mayor yo entendí que eso era lo
máximo pero tampoco me imaginé que nunca
iba a ser algo importante esa dedicación
y ese y esa pasión de
de estar ahí y aprender
y entonces con la lente con la
aniversario con doom fuimos a hacer
prensa y fuimos con unos periodistas
entonces mamainé que es que famosa que
no tiene nada que ver con el carbón y
los vehículos y desde el guayabo mamá y
neil porque yo lo conozco de cuando era
pobre igual que susana baca yo la
conozco antes de cuando era pobre
mayné estos periodistas que te quieren
como se llama que quieren hacer una
entrevista y hace un ratito
para que les cuentes cómo era yo acá
cuando hemos llegado cuando llegado algo
llamado en el 78
entonces ya ya pero ahorita tengo que
cocina no sé qué ahorita vengo yo le
digo a los periodistas mira su hermano
chucho ellos son
ellos son todos son negros ya como dijo
la chica también que empezó todos son
negros y danny mejor amigo chucho
entonces yo le decía yo yo tenía dos o
tres casas donde me quedaba acá en el
guayabo que era donde chucho o de
carlitos barrios donde mamá chicha tal
ya entonces le digo este
pregúntale mickey cómo era que hacía
cata entonces cuando por fin viene a sin
mí que él venía acá él era joven pero
para con todos los negros viejos porque
quería aprender aprendiz y donde se
quedaría no se quedaba en mi casa
entonces todo lo que gente que yo no le
había dicho que ella le diga a ellos o
sea todo lo que
y entonces es un poco así él quería
aprender y por qué para enseñar hay que
aprender uno no puede enseñar sin
aprender de los mayores para aprender
qué es el modesto hay que ser humilde y
mickey siempre lo ha sido
por eso hay gente a la que no le puede
gustar la música de migue gonzález
tampoco a que sea obligatorio o
mandatorio pero nadie podrá decir jamás
que es un mal tipo un arrogante un
sobrado o un idiota
esto es parece que es muy importante si
en un país lleno es muy fuerte
en un país lleno de falsos valores ahora
cuantos mickey son ustedes entonces son
varios los hay en mí que afroperuano
como se diría ahora que esa época no se
hablaba de ese tipo de cultura pero ahí
sí pero hay es miki roqué lo puro
y cuando ya pensábamos que habíamos
conocido a todos los nikis salen mickey
electrónico de inkaterra y todos nos
queremos al helados pero tengo tengo una
sorpresa y hay una sorpresa más si mira
basta por favor mi guía no pues porque
si nos morimos más tarde o mañana o
pasado
esto es importante hasta dónde quiere
llegar de años de edad
de sorpresa a todo lo que pasa a la
gente hay gente que lo sabe pero cuando
yo esos años de los años setenta y
carlos espinoza yo teníamos una amistad
y una pasión de saludo por el tema del
blues
y al conocer la cultura afro auténtica
digamos no la de discos no la de la
televisión sino la auténtica del carmen
yo me quedé ahí un montón de tiempo
entonces yo paraba con los viejos porque
yo quería ser un negro viejo y ahora yo
ya he logrado ser un negro viejo
entonces lo que quería informarles ahora
mi siguiente no sé si el phd o el no sé
que mi siguiente degree que estoy
buscando es ser un chino viejo
no monje budista un chino viejo y como
él como el pequeño saltamontes de lage
con fútbol
como lo ha conseguido ya no nos hablamos
menos pero lo que pasa que yo me atiendo
con un yo metiendo con el doctor este
zoom que es un chino peruano entonces es
muy gracioso porque yo mandé a pochi
marambio en los años 80 para que lo
revisen no entonces el médico china es
muy bacán porque el médico chino te toma
33 pues los mercados chinos famosos
criterios pulso saca lento si hay algo
patológico lo que fuera
te manda a hacer análisis pero él ve
cuáles son los órganos que están como
están funcionando en poner las agujas
entonces yo le decía hoy me vas a poner
en el hígado 3 en el hígado dos citaron
aquí entonces no para
y esto entonces él decía no me caí sabe
de esto porque él va a poner su
consultorio al frente no sé nada pero
por la curiosidad como pregunta le
pregunto pero le dijo lo gracioso fue
imposible pregunta estaba con con su
esposa de esa época le dice oye y mickey
que tiene porque viene acá no es no
tiene nada solo viene a hacerse en
mantenimiento como educar
pero ese es mi ese es mi tema porque
digamos los chinos son tan su cultura es
tan antigua y me fascina porque no sé
por qué pues porque los negros tampoco
conocen porque así que ya yo así que hay
más sorpresas
yo estoy preguntando nada más hay hay
y la penúltima sorpresa es el mic
inflamen concierto el mic y por bulerías
entonces desconcierta a mí ya todo el
mundo y obviamente dice hay otras
sorpresas van a venir porque van a venir
van a venir y eso es que te hace juvenil
eso te hace muy juvenil y esto es algo
que tú pero esto puede terminar si esa
es la conciencia de esos cambios bueno
te lo voy a decir científicamente es que
me desmienta jennifer jane me he
enterado que las neuronas se creían que
las neuronas se destruían pero se
vuelven a regenerar no es así
ya entonces a la persona que me informó
esto lograremos hasta acá pues y cuál es
el cuál es el síntoma y cuál o sea cómo
te sientes cuando se regeneran las
hormonas las hormonas no las neuronas
neuronas porque las neuronas conversan
con hormonas con proteínas así también
ahora después de chino viejo voy a hacer
un peruano viejo
médico peruano al 70
cuando las neuronas se regeneran o nacen
o lo que fuera que tienes nuevas y
frescas te da ganas de hacer cosas y yo
nunca ha dejado de tener ganas de hacer
cosas entonces esa es la prueba de que
las neuronas se regeneran
nunca ha dejado de tener de más y nunca
te has cansado o te cansas más
últimamente
no sé cómo responder porque digamos no
es un cansancio físico es
es un cansancio existencial se podría
decir
porque no lo ha dicho en un tono
cinematográficos prácticamente un poco
[Música]
he dejado el momento un momento de
suspenso no
con esto con esto que ha dicho realmente
un poco misterioso también mi papel pero
la pregunta menos
hasta cuándo vas a mantener la agilidad
que tienes el día de hoy el tiempo no
pasa para ti te veo ágil te veo
completamente vivo o rápido la respuesta
son rápidos se mueven rápidamente al
estado
que dejan como deambulada por todos los
kioskos que había que en el partido
etcétera tienen físico por el rato tengo
físico físicos no oído de tísico oído 25
para mantener el físico
sí
a francia le han preguntado cómo me
mantengo creo que ella es la responsable
francesca en la responsable y yo te
advierto que he consumido aceite de
cannabis
para los efectos terribles de la
radioterapia además con absoluto
conocimiento de los médicos y los
médicos cuando uno da la medicina
alternativa sí pero en realidad hay que
tener en cuenta que la mente es una
forma de competir pero ellos aceptan
también esos cuando son serios y cuando
tienen conocimiento que fue lo que me
pasa a mí para para convertir los
efectos comparativos a efectos adversos
de la radioterapia
ahí es todo que tú has recibido también
como yo pues aquí
a ver me vino bien el falta de la
corrupción que tenía tenía un haber que
levante la mano todos los que han visto
un espectáculo me últimamente
y otros
la planchita
[Aplausos]
yo mismo no creo que vayas diseño de
diseño de ustedes ya ustedes ya lo
conocían sabían quién era sabían que era
un buen tipo sabía que es un tipo de
gracioso
parece que nos conocemos del doral y
cínico jurídico como dice ver - y sólo
jesús da la impresión de que este
muchacho se le conoce de toda la vida
que es algo íntimo de todos nosotros y
eso solamente son muy pocas las personas
que llegan a ese nivel de santidad
y uno de ellos es nada menos que señoras
y señores miki gonzález
[Música]
en el metro
[Aplausos]
[Música]